The point of us doing the one-pager is we want to see how the market's going to react.
We want to see, before I go spend money on a domain and all this stuff and actual content,
I want to see what kind of volume I'm going to get for my ads.
I want to see if I can get a business owner on the hook that's going to pay and fund my
property.
That's why I do it.
Now, if you've done really strong due diligence, you're confident in it, no problem.
There is value in getting the domain live, indexed, and starting to rank, no question,
but for me personally, I like to do the one-pager because I will not build, will not build unless
I have somebody that's got a credit card on file.